[Music]
do you guys use cash anymore
no no what is this look i don't even
have space for it
but i'm talking about real cats
sometimes for like haircuts
sometimes i use venmo i do actually try
to use it more now because i'm just
trying to like
here keep the change because i don't
want any like don't touch my credit card
when i'm at the strip club i usually
just go start dancing and i go were you
dancing
i told the lady start dancing i started
hitting the vemble button
it's not the same as throwing money it's
not that i went to the taco truck
i know and i didn't have cash and i went
hey can i brought 20 bucks
to who australia my friend my friend's
friend
anyway so this story here it takes place
in the uk
and it's around this woman this 60 year
old
sweet woman named megan so she's been
working at this bakery
for over 40 years
she's been working there for 44 years
and it has been her fault that she's
been working there
yeah that's you know at a bakery you
gotta wake up at like three in the
morning and start baking
well i don't know if she bakes but i do
know that so what's she doing at a
bakery if she ain't baking
she's worked there for 44 years and 25
of them as a manager
oh man of bacon she opens the door
she watches people bake more yeast if
she's good
curl those croissants more yup needs a
little more curl
icing on the cake icing on the cake
she's just barking orders all day
yup yeah 25 of those years to be
sharpens the door three o'clock parker
okay so this is the bakery she had
worked at bird's bakery
in the uk man they do bread out there in
europe so good though and you
uh i don't know about the uk though i
haven't ate any bread out there and i
was like that's
that's so good no what's up with all
those confederate flags though
wait they got the confederate flag no
just kidding
that's the union jack oh my gosh
anyway so megan
because of this pandemic that we
currently are living through
a lot of places a lot of restaurants
have decided to
no longer accept cash because they don't
want the germs transferring and like
putting people at risk right yeah so
megan
she started seeing a lot because a lot
of the customers
of this bakery they were elderly people
and so she started having they don't
[ __ ] with venmo
she started having to turn away a lot of
elderly people that like they had
gotten their bread they took it up to
the till to the cashier
and then like they were gonna pay for it
but then they don't have any
they don't have a credit card or debit
card any of that so they
she would have to turn them away and it
just broke her heart so she was like you
know what
here just give me the cash and i'll put
it on my card and then like you'll be
good to go she's just trying to get
points i know that's what i'm saying i'm
getting
cheat now it works though because then
she said like if i did
if i kept having to turn them away then
then the items that they picked they
would
either have to be thrown out or cleaned
really
yeah cause they're like you got those
geezer germs now it's not just geezer
it's just germs coven germs pandemic
times you know
yeah damn that's how we do it like if
you touch the bread cause i go to
bakeries and [ __ ] no
and they have them in the back and then
they'll be like um
they'll have them in a bag and you just
choose you'll be like okay let me get
the swirly swirl one with the sugar on
top and then let me get um no like this
it's all just a cinnabon brush
baby you can't just grab them right
i mean they should have done that
because you have people like me that go
over at the bakery and we're just like
nah that one doesn't look bad i mean if
you guys have been to like [ __ ]
you're wearing gloves right
no everyone does that i do it i do that
like 85 degrees
don't tell me that i go there and then i
go i use the tongs though
that's a different connection then i
squeeze the bread and i go oh
they made it soft today grab a couple of
these guys okay
pick it up like that examine it no no i
keep it sanity you go to the grocery
store and you [ __ ] push the bag
and you pick it up and you [ __ ] i
hate people that push the bag because
then you're gonna [ __ ] it up
well you hate me then because i do that
[ __ ] everywhere
even if i'm not buying bread that day
i'm just stress reliever
now you know why your fruits always
bruise when you get it you know what
that just made me think of in the
mexican markets i wonder if they still
have the piccolos laid out
for you to stick your hands in oh yeah
and the rice and the rice
i wonder wait they they have it for you
to stick your hand in there no
it's a scooper right it just feels bomb
yeah it smells amazing like that was my
childhood like satisfaction don't you do
that at like the nice starbucks where
they have the coffee beans out
nice starbucks starbucks reserves oh
they're too fancy for us well you know
well no no really like if like coffee
beans are in like a barrel i have to
also go into that i understand that what
my childhood dream is
at the supermarket getting the tongs and
taking the crabs and putting it on the
floor
[Applause]
we didn't have live things in mexican
markets that's chronology and then my
mom has to pick between either
getting the crab or beating my ass and
she's usually stuck in the middle like
kick his ass or get the crackers and
then while she's thinking
while she's thinking i put another crab
on the ball oh my god
bart i'm gonna kick your childhood ass
like jesus tycho is not far so you're
not gonna get the crabs in
that's for sure i'm not getting the
crabs but first i'm beating little bart
and then i'm going to
go to the shopping cart i just push it
it was funny my dad taught me that
to put on the floor no he would
he's like the first thing that we would
do and go nine-nine rat goes you ready
to go with the fish here and i'm like
[ __ ] yeah and he would give me his keys
[ __ ] yeah i get the keys and then i get
to poke the [ __ ] gooey duck
and then the clams his keys yeah
i use the keys he just stabbed again so
i'll be the one doing it he's just
watching me laughing
wow he's like oh i can't get in trouble
if he's just doing it yeah
that did remind me that my dad was the
one who taught me to poke fish's
eyeballs
why are you guys doing it it's in the
plastic it's like it's already covered
and i'm just poking still
i don't know anyway back to the story
see i got to check the meat i was taught
by my parents
i mean to be fair did anybody here like
find snails in their backyard and put
like salt on them
never you freaking me neither for sure
me neither totally my cousin did that
all the time
right your cousin's an [ __ ]
well you're gonna come back as a snail
bro my korean homies would get the
ladies would get the shenanigan packets
and cut it and then sprinkle it on the
snail
oh no that's a waste i know but i don't
know why they did that but
they thought it was funny it shrivels up
we were like i don't know
eight years old just well i'm like
internally judging myself because i'm
like damn that sounds kind of fun
i kind of want to see what that's like
but no it's like your childhood fun
right yeah yeah but now you're like oh
[ __ ] up but as a kid
yeah now you've learned it's evil but
you still like it yeah that's bad
no it's not that i like it yeah yeah
right yeah that's disgusting my cousin
was like that like
when after when it was raining he's like
it's raining
right and he grabs the scissors and he
grabbed the whole thing of salt and he
goes outside
and you cut the eyes of the snail and
cover it in salt
what yeah and i was like five or
something
so while it's going like this yeah well
it's going like this he's just like
yeah yeah when the eyes come out he
would [ __ ] cut him
you can't judge his cousin now you put
some i didn't say i did that i was
wondering out of my own curiosity if
anybody partook in such
evil acts yeah two-step evil act
yeah but then i'm watching the whole
thing this was better oh my god and he
was cracking the [ __ ] up
technically three steps with two eyes i
wouldn't know i'm just
they have two eyes what sucks too is
everybody moves in fast motion compared
to the snail they're like
is this supposed to be like no no no no
no no no no no no
the salt happens too the speed is like
yeah
i wouldn't know i wouldn't know crazy i
just hypothetically i was like this is
the fastest i've ever
moved see it's turbo in his head
damn it turn oh wow you put a name on it
no i know what i'm talking about that's
what i'm saying now i see a face that
we're cutting the eyes off
do you feel terrible i feel turbo i know
my mom
in vietnam because you know she's poor
jungle little
woman or a little girl yeah and she i
know she used to like
play with crickets and she would like
take their heads off and put them on
sticks and play with them and stuff
but like that wasn't a doll yeah you
didn't have the toys there so they just
played with dead crickets
oh man i mean that's a jungle life yeah
jungle life
i mean my mom lived a poor life too and
she found like joy in
cutting like plucking out the wings of
ladybugs so they won't fly away and she
taught me to do that and like i feel
really well
so they wouldn't but at least it's like
still alive i guess you know you're like
it's your pet anyway i'm getting
depressed let's go back to the story so
megan remember though the 60 year old
woman who would pay with the credit card
credit card point scammer yeah yeah
so trying to get that free massage at
the mgm
oh my god okay so this is what she said
i realized what i was doing was against
company policy but they had
but they had picked up the items and had
already gone to the table to buy them
there was no way i could let an elderly
man or woman walk away
telling them they could not buy it
because isn't she elderly herself
yeah true um so anyway what ended up
happening is that she got suspended for
a week
with pay and they they were looking into
like well what really happened
and it concluded with her losing her job
oh yeah she got fired and so she put him
44 years there though 44 years
what if she was just pocketing the money
and never actually used her credit card
no no so
no so she kept the receipts of of the
customers
44 years and then you got fired for
trying to be nice to like neighborhood
like senior citizens
is this a corporate place though it
seems like it's not mom and pop um
it seems like they have a chain i don't
know for a fact but
chain places usually [ __ ] up on the
human side of things a lot yeah
damn yeah so not even a warning
no there's like a change.org petition
for her
for megan and so as of right now they've
gotten 16
189 it's climbing as i'm saying this
now it's 92. um and they're trying to
get to 25 000
signatures to and then like what they're
asking for
is to give megan back her job can you
imagine
being yeah one of the owners of this
chain and then middle management does
something stupid like this
and it's a reflection of you i would
[ __ ] call a meeting just
to have an hour speech of how [ __ ]
stupid
the decision maker was was it like a
corporation decision or like a
like a franchise owner decision you know
what i mean like the
if it is a chain is it still the
responsibility of like the
particular manager or owner of that well
they're saying it's like company policy
so
this is what one of the representatives
of the company said a lot of our
customers base
a customer base are the elderly many of
them vulnerable and it is our
responsibility to keep them and our
staff
safe like many other food outlets during
this pandemic we have asked customers to
only use debit cards because notes and
coins are not clean
and this poses a risk to our staff who
are handling the money
and so she was saying they were saying
that megan not only when it went
went against company policy but she also
went against
current covent 19 safety guidelines i
mean
it kind of makes sense right like if he
she gets something from somebody now
she's just spreading on whatever else
she touches
i get it but that just shows your as a
leader that just shows that
you can just be like you're just
negligible you know like you can
replace the ball yeah yeah like tossed
out that's kind of [ __ ] up
that just tells me that that company
didn't figure out a better solution
so that their customers
can purchase like if they know that most
of their customers are elderly then why
don't they [ __ ]
appeal to that demo yeah what if they're
is there like a reverse atm
like a coin star kind of like that
yeah huh like a vending machine you just
put the money in and it just counts it
yeah or like just like pay and there's
no change
oh but then that's yours fire her
and have a robot just deposit the money
because robots can't get
corona right so that pay no change thing
is what's happening right now in
california
really yeah yeah because they're like
corn shortage there's a coin shortage
yeah yeah a lot of fast food places like
back to check in the box i went to jack
of the dogs earlier and they were
actually had a sign saying like if you
give us
a roll of 10 a 10 roll of quarters you
get two free tacos
whoa but they're giving free food just
for coins because yeah isn't that crazy
there's a coin shortage yeah that's
because it's probably
corn hordage
[Music]
you